the most malevolent application of my
work would be for people to learn how to
not get caught when they perpetrate
serious laws how to actually become
better at lying in most interactions we
have with other people we seek honesty
in fact on most of the public opinion
polls that have been done it comes up as
the first or second most important
criteria in terms of who we're gonna
have as a friend the relationships we
want with our children with our partner
or spouse we want them to be honest with
us I've been asked by a sitting
president I won't say which one to
enhance their credibility in in other
words make them more successful as a
liar and of course I would never vote
for a president who I didn't think could
lie we don't want our political leaders
when they deal with other political
leaders to put all our cards face up we
don't want them to be totally
untrustworthy either so it's a fine line
that's walked between truth and
dishonesty Kissinger not a politician
that are enormous ly admire but in his
book on diplomacy he said it's accepted
if we conceal our true beliefs our
bottom line but to ever actually say
something false ruins you for future
diplomatic encounters so you can conceal
but you can't falsify when my wife comes
and says I just bought this new dress
what do you think of it she wants me to
say that's smashing but I say that I
don't flatter so if I think it's the
wrong color or the wrong cup that's what
I'll tell her that's not what she wants
she wants this smashing but I've tried
to convince her over more than three
decades they
it's useful to have someone who will
tell you the truth